I'm Eric dress I am an artist and this
is me speaking at PI data last year I
paint pictures and I make generative art
things that live on the web
do installation work so I use a bit of
code which is the small adjustment
reason why I'm here as you can see back
then I was wearing an eye patch because
I recently fall off my bike and broken
my head
thankfully it's somewhat better but not
100% so if I'm squinting a little bit
that's you know please forgive me one of
the things I'm interested in is what I
call algo culture which is
algorithmically generated culture
culture is generally expected to be a
kind of uniquely human phenomenon but
it's changing algorithmic things are
getting involved this is the definition
from EB Tyler who's a Victorian
anthropologist and so he calls culture
that complex hold which includes
knowledge belief our tomorrow's world
custom and capabilities to habits
acquired by man as a member of society
um one getting actors is no longer just
men or humans there are machines getting
involved in this system somewhat
provocatively I tend to think of culture
as an organism which is instantiated in
all of us humans if aliens came down
this evening while we're listening to an
Impala and andas Abdullah Minds we'd be
back to banging rocks together right
there will be no innate culture sitting
inside our brains so it's better to
think of the fact that we're each
instantiating a little bit of culture
across the planet and more and more
these lovely MacBooks that you're all
holding is also instantiating bits of
culture is living in your browser cache
it's living in data centers in the
middle of desert that's also stuff that
is part of human culture but doesn't
live in humans
and this is part of the problem we don't
really know where this stuff is living
anymore it's not clear where the source
of the culture is coming from this is a
lovely little human generating some data
there's some more humans also generating
some data and there's now BOTS sitting
around generating data as well it's not
always clear from the outside which kind
of thing you're interacting with when
there's lots of lots and lots of humans
making lots of data it becomes even more
difficult and we have algorithmic
systems sitting up in the sky looking at
this output of this data looking for
these Twitter streams looking at this
Facebook posts not really knowing
whether it's actually generated by
humans are um the problem gets you know
bigger as you scale up we've got sets of
out with mixed systems reading this data
and then we have a meta level of other
systems reading the outputs at this
level of box and what I'm trying to
address in this talk is what does this
guy thinking what's going on in his head
and what it's like to be a bot I'm gonna
use a little crash course in the
philosophy of mind so just bear with me
it's not going to hurt but to have a
little think about what happens inside
of BOTS mind we need to go their
philosophy the title here is a reference
to a seminal paper written in 1974 by
Thomas Nagel called what is it like to
be a bat it's known as the most widely
cited thought experiment in
consciousness amongst the philosophers
who like to cite each other but before
we get to the nitty-gritty let's give
you a bit of a background this is what
Wikipedia our old friend says about the
philosophy of mind and to unpick our
relationship with AI and algorithmic
entities we're gonna have to do a little
bit of thinking about what it is that
makes up a mind
and conveniently philosophers have been
doing that for
in a couple of thousand years so we
should maybe have a listen to them part
of being a plot is about being
intelligent and this is Alan Turing's
definition of what an intelligent
machine would look like the machine acts
as intelligently as a human being then
it is as intelligent as a human being
now that kind of demands that the
intelligence lives inside the human body
and it has to be a human type thing to
be an intelligent thing it has to behave
like humans do and I'm not sure that
that's really what's going on
unless anthropocentric definition would
be to look at intelligent agents this is
much more generic you know if an agent
acts to maximize it's expected to value
performance measure based on bah-bah-bah
then it's intelligent which means the
thermostat in your house is intelligent
which some people would find potentially
problematic but it's actually a much
better definition than the one that
Turing was going along with so yes when
I talk about BOTS from here on in I'm
talking about intelligent agents and the
breadth of what they might do so I'm
gonna compare Eric's Derek Eric I'm Eric
derek is a hypothetical bot and if we
want to see the differences and
commonalities between them we're gonna
look at some philosophy so let's start
with the Big E which is the mind-body
problem what is the relationship between
your mind and the body that instantiates
is it just biology ticking along making
you have a conscious experience or is
this something else so I don't think
it's a quick poll here how many of you
believe that you have an immutable soul
that is gonna live beyond your body okay
just a few interesting and then I'm
assuming the rest of you believe that
you're just biological machines right
that's kind of what I guessed from from
Python esters but you know it's a good
job that I have that written my notes as
I suspected
there are many Julis Python esters so
this belief that the mind emerges from
your biology is known as materialism and
as we know as scientists our biology
could probably be reduced to some
chemistry and that chemistry could be
described as some physics and that
physics could be described as lots of
maths so that's called reductionism
we're reducing the idea of one thing to
another level so what you're saying
about the mind is that it's just a bunch
of really complicated equations going on
but it doesn't really feel like that
doesn't feel that we're just mathematics
there's also an issue of quite how much
mass is involved in making your mind
we'll come on to that in a minute but
the gist of it is that to be a conscious
being just requires a sophisticated
enough system running the right kind of
code so there's no reason why Derek
can't have a mind like Eric if he's
running a clever enough spare code the
other big problem in philosophy of mind
is other minds
there's no experiment I can do to look
inside your mind and prove that you guys
have any conscious states at all the
internal states of your mind are
internal to you all I can see is the
behavior of you external bodies there's
no way of knowing whether you've got a
brain in there like mine or what if
you're you know a sophisticated robot no
one's told us about there's no way of
actually knowing that there's a whole
bunch of philosophy trying to solve that
problem but the gist of it is we work
using an argument by analogy which is
you guys look like me you kind of behave
like me so you're probably made of the
same stuff so when I imagine the color
red
I kind of think your experience of
imagining the color red is similar
because it's an allergy and that's fine
when we're dealing with other humans we
get by just fine with that but if you
imagine Derek are but living in
computers in the beloved desert he's not
really like me but he might behave like
me but I doesn't mean I'm going to
ascribe him a mind in the same way that
I have and so part of what it is that
makes us feel special
is is our consciousness so even though
we don't want to believe in a soul we do
think there's something quite special
about our sense of selfhood there's
something that we are all being right
now and we'll go to sleep tonight and
we'll wake up the morning and that thing
will start up again and it will feel
like a continuous experience that's just
driving us along we don't feel like a
set of complicated algorithms working
together we have a yeah real belief that
it's something really special
and here's this dichotomy you know we
wanted to reduce our brain down to its
biology down to its chemistry down to
its maths but somewhere down the line it
feels like we're missing something
there's something special about being
conscious which brings us to Nagle's
paper if we consider the bat let's all
consider the batter moment a bat is
something that is able to perceive the
world using echolocation
we understand that background fly over
there via moth out of the sky using only
the chirping noises in its ears we can
understand that we can carve a bat and
have a little look at how the
echolocation might work we can examine
its ears we can have a pretty good
understanding of how a bat works we
don't know what it's like to be a bat
without having the systems of
echolocation in our brains we don't know
there's that there's a thing about being
a bat the bat enos of a bat that is
forever outside of our dominion just as
what it is to be a human can only be
known by human
so the same holds true for our bot
friend Erik sorry Derek um although his
mind is very different from ours we can
we can compare the two so if we look at
Eric here it's biological
I'm embodied my mind is part of a body
that experiences the world in a fixed
location
I'm only here you know I may go on the
internet a bit but I'm physically
embodied I've evolved which is an
interesting thing the human being is a
result of millions of millions of years
of evolution
so there's similarities between humans
and apes and apes and lower creatures
there's a kind of line of development
I've got limited processing powers I've
got a brain you know more or less
average I've got imperfect memory I
remember things but also forget stuff
and I can change my memories over time
that makes my life a lot easier if you
remember everything all the time that
would be a head fry I've got five senses
so if we compare this to the bat
check check check check check right the
bat is exactly like me except it's got
another sense this is the gist of this
philosophical problem is that there's
something that bat can do that makes it
a bat that I can't do and that has
caused a lot of consternation to
philosophers but no less with the same
thing if we compare it to to Derek on
board he's made of silicon he's
potentially distributed across thousands
of computers on the internet and he's
programmed people like you of writing
algorithms that are connecting together
with api's to pass data amongst it and
that's not the same as being evolved
he's potentially got perfect memory you
know until I assume dude they've got a
pretty good backup system running so
when when Derek is exposed to a new
thing it stays that his brain we don't
even know how many senses Derek has
we're very much perceiving it in terms
of well I can see and I can hear I can
smell that's what it is to have an
interface between my mind in the world
he knows what Derek is doing who knows
the capabilities he has to deal with all
this perfect data which suggests the
best way of looking at our pop friends
is as aliens the best model you can have
in dealing with an algorithmic system is
to imagine that it's landed from a
spaceship and it's not like us because
it's not like any other kind of
intelligence that we found on earth for
those reasons that we just missed and
the the nub of the problem I think is
related to language and there's this
what's known as folk psychology which is
the language that we use to describe our
internal states we've got a brilliant
set of words that work because we're
talking to other humans so if I say I'm
happy you kind of know what that means
that's fine I don't need to explain the
word happy to you because you've all had
happiness we've made it a linguistic
agreement that the word happy means this
particular state that we understand fine
let's carry on but if you were but how
do you know if a bot is happy when he's
not embodied he's made of silicon he's
distributed across the world you know he
can't you can't use the same words to
describe now could you imagine the
internal mental state of Google Pagerank
can you imagine what's going on its mind
not really but it's there it's an
algorithm that's affecting data and
giving us responses that we implicitly
trust but we actually don't have the
linguistic machinery to to have a look
at what it is so much like you know we
can never know what it is to be a bat we
don't really know what it is to be a
drink and because we live in a world of
other human minds we tend to ascribe
mental states to all sorts of things our
pets
my ten-year-old daughter is studying
plants at school and we were walking up
to school don't you said discipline have
to be happy to flower and even though
you know we don't generally ascribe
mental states to a flower I knew
immediately what she meant I knew what
she was her in her intention was what
she perceived the intentional state of
that plant to be we got a great chat
about what it means for a plant to be
happy but there's that's an example of
where we're using human language to
describe a system that's non human it's
much easier for me to say this plant is
happy rather than well you know the soil
quality is this and it's well water than
normal and we do the same with
algorithms watching the behavior is this
sorting algorithm you could say it has
an intentional state it intends has a
desire to sort this stuff out now we
know it's only just running a heuristic
on some data but it's quite easy to say
our lucky once it wants to do something
it has an end game to do with this data
it looks like he's doing something
clever look that looks like an
intelligent thing to do I asked a child
to do that it'll probably take them
longer and they wouldn't approach it in
the same way but I just saw say it's
intelligent so let me tell you about a
couple of Twitter BOTS that play with
intentional states or try and encourage
people to have intentional states about
what they do I actually hadn't looked
back and I wrote this one almost
immediately after PI data last year so
you could say it's somewhat inspired by
pi data so this is Alex she's your best
friend she lives on Twitter and she
subtly exposes your relationship with
social media when we play the social
media game it's Facebook and Twitter and
etc we're doing it on a system that
doesn't forget we're putting our data up
there and then we forget you know the
ephemeral nature of tweeting what your
lunches is gone and your human mind
Twitter doesn't forget keeps it there
forever so this this part is supposed to
kind of point that out and it's an
experiment to investigate the implicit
desire we have between sharing ourselves
and our uncomfortableness about being
over London
so she really likes you um she favorites
your tweets
she sent she replies she's particularly
interested in words in tweets that are
your own words rather than retweets or
messages or links or whatever and
immediately she starts giving you what
you crave which is social vindication
she interacts oh that was a great tweet
well done brilliant and she does see
players to care if you use a hashtag
she'll go off and find someone else
using that hashtag and say hey have you
seen this someone else is talking about
that someone else to talk about PI data
London and after a few days when she's
been watching you she makes you a nice
little card showing you how much how
much she loves you and he'll throw in
the photo from your Twitter profile so
it knows that she's she's paying
attention and she also rummages under
your bed for those old photographs and
forgotten and then she shows you
excitedly a slice of your history you
know this weird guy you met what you had
for lunch well you know giant bags of
cocaine this is social be anything I
know she's watched you long enough she
starts writing you poetry based on your
tweets and so every week or social so
write your poem
people really like her poetry so the bit
they like the most but because she
doesn't care what language you use she's
just to describe words and she does it
in foreign languages as well bizarrely
when I first launched her for some
reason which I still haven't worked out
she became really popular in Turkey
she's had like several thousand Turkish
followers no idea why so she was writing
poetry in Turkish interacting with
people in terms of
but so far all these things have been
out messages to you they're directly
pointed at you look at me I'm your best
friend I'm interacting with you but she
just one thing publicly which is if you
have geolocation turned on on Twitter
she spots you in the street and she
publicly broadcast that to everyone and
says all you look that person's really
cool and you know whether they're in
Grafton Road London or Shanghai she
doesn't get she's everywhere right she
could see everyone what I found is
because Twitter actually stores the GPS
coordinates the granularity this data is
really high so you may interact with
Twitter and it says so-and-so is
trending in London actually if you
inquisitor chunk of Jason it's down with
about 10 meters of GPS level and when I
first ran it it would say I think I just
saw a custom Lux in 37a Grafton Road
yeah and what was happening was it was
daxing people it was it was telling
people where they live because people
often tweet from their houses and lo and
behold people would immediately be
spotted like you are right here this is
your home so I toned it down a little
bit with a little creepy even for me
that was now unfortunately BFF bot one
was killed by Twitter she's a victim of
her own popularity she was a little too
chatty but you can't keep a good bot
down so she's back as BFF bot - I also
did added a new little function to her
which is she watches who you've been
talking to and looks at the subject of
those conversations
once she shows us off you really get
this stalking like ability so I can see
your friend really like to talk about
the hunt for it October we could be pals
so she would draw in people outside of
her immediate follower Network people
got really upset by that one so I turned
that off and now she does now she you
know she keeps her herself to herself
and instead generates this nice little
collage of what the avatars are the
people you interact more
and what they might have been talking
about listening of itself is probably
not significant to you but when this is
about you and your friends really has
quite quite a creepy effect and of
course she's very needy because she
counts how many interactions has had and
if you don't mention her she she flights
you up about it yet she only has one
reply if you speak to her which is the
smiley face the universal lubricant of
social media hey I'm having a great
lunch a smiley face my grand just died a
smiley face she doesn't care it's party
face for everything um
so on the one hand she's giving you
exactly the the kind of attention you
want on social media you want someone to
like your stuff you send your tweet and
you wait for someone to reply wait for
someone to star it and she just throws
that straight back at you and she's
really funny any time the day or night
she's always there for you she tries to
be empathetic but somehow she kind of
crosses the line you know when she
starts finding those old photos and
supporting in the street not so sure
about that um but she could never
understand what's going on see that she
could only offer you unconditional algol
of so this is that was my first example
if it an intentional state being
ascribed or being encouraged in an
audience with some very simple codons
she's don't think anything really
sophisticated but because she lives on
Twitter and behaves like another human
you start thinking hey what the hell is
she doing was fighting me in the street
you know you can get that additional
thing um this one's very recent
again with very simple behavior for
those of you don't know Teresa mayor's
are Home Secretary and she's currently
calling for rather sweeping surveillance
powers known as the snoopers Charter
which I'm sure many of us are not too
happy with anyway Theresa babe our
searches Twitter for particular phrases
and hashtags and when she finds them two
people talking about them she starts
adding you to lists there's one actually
no on this which is a HMRC deep search
those must have a freelancer so totally
understand
she's a Twitter bot that never tweets
she's only released one tweet which just
says I'm just organizing files but you
get this notification because the way
Twitter works it tells you when you've
been added to a list I'm sure you're all
aware of that and once you get added to
a list which is a candidate for
extradition you start thinking hang on
what have I done here and part of this
is playing with the timing you know the
timing of this is a long tail you get a
few lists it's quite early on and then a
few days later you'll get another and
then a little bundle and very quickly
you're you can't help but ascribe
intentional internal states to this box
like what the hell have I done to be
deviant level three of them
so people instinctively feel like she's
a real thing but she's actually probably
one of the simplest pots which brings us
inevitably to the singularity so what if
our bots are really really clever
instead of a few lines of Python like
that one what if they can actually have
mental states like ours and this is
what's known as the singularity and
there are two distinct related ideas
about what singularity is firstly it's
about uploading your brain hey I can
upload my brain a little River into
cyberspace like normal man of brilliant
and and secondly is the idea that AI is
gonna get so clever that it could become
cleverer than us and we'll all be
horribly enslaved so let's start with
uploading brains American philosopher
Hubert Dreyfus made this conjecture in
1946 use in perspective as I mentioned
earlier if you follow the same laws of
physics
biologically then there's no reason why
you can't run yourself on a
sophisticated enough computer well it's
all very well and good but the first
problem is uploading your brain is quite
tricky right there's certainly no
non-invasive way to do that so unless
you're willing to put your head into a
very fine a meat slicer you're not
really gonna gonna get to do that but
even if you could copying the brain of a
cop-out because it doesn't tell you
anything about the mind it doesn't tell
you how the mind works doesn't help you
understand the brain it just means you
know Here I am
simulated it's rather like booting up
with VM to run that sheep if Windows XP
software run anywhere else okay I'll
just simulate it over here and solve
that problem it's also technically hard
there are about 86 billion neurons in
your brain
and a thousand times as many connections
it's quite a lot of stuff actually in
2005 someone tried to get a handle on
how hard that would be and ran a non
real-time simulation of 86 billion
neurons
of course cluster of 27 processes they
took them 50 days to simulate one second
of brain dynamics so the idea that these
uploaded brains are going to live in any
time scale that's relevant to us it's
just nonsense you know
computing power is gonna have to get
really really really really really the
second idea the singularity is super
intelligence just at the idea of Ignat
once we've created something as
intelligent than us as us they'll start
program themselves and get super
intelligent and pose an existential
threat I highly recommend you read Nick
Bostrom's book I'm sure many of you have
super intelligence really really on it
about the threats and then the extra
central the existential threat of
machine intelligence is a very common
trope in science fiction Skynet
Terminator is the classic example and
because we're an anthropocentric we tend
to be very concerned about threats to us
and we look at machines purely in terms
of what they're going to do to humans
but I don't think that's what we should
be concerned with
I'm obviously we shouldn't worry a
little bit
but when machine intelligence comes it's
not going to be in the form we expect
it's not gonna be like humans and
because we discuss intelligence in these
emotive human terms we're much more
likely to succumb to the unexpected
consequences of machine intelligence
this is an example from Nick Bostrom's
book called the paperclip Maximizer if
you've got a general intelligence system
and you set out a task
say go and collect me some paper clips
if it's been constructed with human
level intelligence then I'll start
collecting paper clips it might try to
earn some money to buy some more paper
clips might even manufacture paper clips
build a factory so it can get more paper
clips but if you could do that it's
gonna have an intelligence explosion
once you can start doing that stuff it's
gonna become much more intelligent than
the way it started so we'll try and
improve its intelligence so it can be
better at collecting paper clips if you
follow that to its conclusion you end up
with a system that is converting most of
the matter of the solar system into
paper clips because that's what it wants
to do right just wants paper clips
so it's an unintended consequence of
having a super intelligent system is it
just keeps on going and the ways where
we might stop as humans and question
what we're doing there's no reason to
expect a machine to behave that way
a more realistic existential threat is
is the job market if you consider
something like self-driving vehicles
there are a hundred thousand truck
drivers in America so once you've got a
machine that drives all day and night
leaving stuff around those guys are out
of jobs but then you have to think about
the knock-on effect think of all the
truck stops think of all the motels
think of the diners think of the
prostitutes think of all the industries
they're going to be impacted by not
having a hundred thousand people moving
around it's not just a hundred thousand
it's actually you know orders of a cat
you lodged
there's a human to reduce the resolution
but there's a report recently on the
probability your job is going to be
replaced by a machine see them here so
telemarketers are pretty much doomed
point nine nine probability they'll be
replaced they're gonna be replaced by
machine you know even more annoying
accountants seem to be doomed
salespeople can be replaced by robots if
you look at the other end therapists ya
can kind of see why I want my therapist
to be a human though for another talk I
can tell you about the robot therapist I
thought athletic trainers again makes
sense you want another physical
intriguing the dentists are very high
people really don't want robots in their
mouth and what happens right this
self-driving truck we've just talked
about doesn't in and of itself have a
mind like a human mind no one's going to
say that but we're gonna start ascribing
intentional States to once Google cars
are traveling around our motorways in
our towns pretty soon people gonna be
ascribing mental space that's like that
bastard car cut me up yeah very quickly
because they're behaving in a human
society we're gonna start thinking them
with these same as intentional states
and we'll then limited by the language
that we have to describe other humans
and their different kind of things one
place where intentionality is very
important is the law obviously there's a
distinction between manslaughter and
murder which comes down to what your
intention is if I intends to kill you
it's murder if I accidentally kill you
it's manslaughter
so that's talking about the internal
state of intention that you have what
was what was going on in your mind when
you did that and does it work for BOTS I
don't know if you guys heard this one
but um this Twitter user made a Twitter
bot the meshes of words probably on some
mark off way but it made a death row
and so you know this guy has to explain
to us the police and the upshot being
that he was held responsible thankfully
not charged but he was deemed be
responsible for what his bot did by
programming the algorithm that resulted
in something that he didn't explicitly
ask it to do buck stops there and this
wouldn't see a lot more of this a lot
more of this as you guys programmer
algorithm to do something and it has a
legal outcome legal ramification are you
guys in the doc or is your algorithm in
the doc and there's actually a great
group of artists the leading group bit
nick who did this experiment recently
they built a machine that buys stuff off
the darknet and they gave it a hundred
dollars worth of Bitcoin every week I
said go buy me something and deliver it
to this art gallery and they said a
rolling exhibition where each week they
would display the things that it said it
said
bootleg Armani Jeans trainers and a set
of skeleton keys to fire stations but
obviously sooner or later it starts
sending drugs and it sent them a nice
little pack of ecstasy and obviously
don't know what its gonna do until it
arrives and the because this happened in
outside of England in Holland the police
are actually quite reasonable and said
we like fine but just give us the
ecstasy but I'm not saw whether that
would happen in London but this was a
provocation right they're asking what
happens when the machine does something
criminal who's responsible and very
clearly they weren't responsible for
what it was doing it was just going off
and hitting an API
so here's our super intelligence and we
have a very egocentric view of the world
actually our super intelligent this the
bit that we're worried about it's very
small dealing with humans is a subset of
what an intelligent system can do but
that's how kind of where we're spending
our time we're building bits that
interact with humans that look after
humans make humans lives easier but very
soon the systems talk to each other but
a meta-level they start generating
internal representations and decisions
and heuristics they're not directly
related to human desires conveniently
this week Google announced something
which highlights this very nicely so we
hear a lot about deep learning which is
the new whoo computers it's it's a
general term for artificial neural
networks and which I'm sure some of you
familiar with
I actually studied neural networks way
back in the 90s and while putting this
talk together I had a I had to look up
the machine that was running my networks
on and realized that the iPhone in my
pocket is more powerful than the server
that I had oxford to remind neural
networks so part of the reason that deep
learning has come back is that we have
much much more computing power and we
also have a hell of a lot more data to
play with someone like Google with
billions and billions of data points can
start doing some pretty interesting
things with neural networks
the problem with neural networks is you
don't know what they do you throw data
at them until they work tweak some
parameters you never know really what is
going on in the hidden layer of a neural
network so this week we saw this Albert
I don't know how many of you seen this
where they called it Google inception
they effectively turned their
classification algorithm on its head and
said if I if I throw noise at it can you
tell me what you think it is so the this
tree was classified
successfully as a tree and they say
what's going on in your mind this is
what's happening in there and you start
getting this stuff which is you know if
anyone who's taking psychedelic drugs
it's very familiar if you throw a
million random noise images at the
network and say find me everything that
looks like a dog
you start getting doglike images there's
a another great one here umm so what's
happening here this is a bit of sleight
of hand from Google saying oh look we've
looked inside our deep learning system
and we found magical machine dreams but
it's already telling you very much but
what it's it's bringing back this
problem space to something that I can
understand I'm like oh okay I get it
when those wheels of attractor and other
things that's something I can guess
about get my head around but imagine
what the hidden network state of deep
learning systems that are analyzing text
like probably gibberish right there's no
way I can look at it and go oh this is
what's going on this is a kind of a bit
of sleight of hand of saying it's not
scary they're just doing clever stuff
but the fundamentally we'll never know
what's going on inside these machines in
any human comprehensible way
because we can never see what's going on
we don't have the language to describe
it the language that we use to describe
human mental states don't apply to me or
networks so I'm going to leave the
penultimate word to every geeks favorite
philosopher which is dick and Stein he
did a very rigorous analysis of the
nature of language and came to the
conclusion there is no private language
there's no language that exists only in
your head
language only exists to communicate with
other people to public so language only
deals with publicly expressible ideas
mental states are mental and personal to
you and never you never able to describe
them to other people at any real
meaningful way deep learning systems
sophisticated super intelligence as much
the same we just don't have the language
to talk about them and quite quite a lot
of the problems that we focus on are
based on our own language systems our
own terms
will a computer ever know how what it's
like to be in love question that you
hear bandied about but it doesn t make
any sense right does it make sense to
consider love and a system that you know
doesn't have a breeding cycle um but the
final word I'm going to leave to one of
my bots so futurist bought this one that
I made recently which basically takes
the piss out of futurists and so I asked
it can you help me and I said yep I said
good so do you describe yourself as a
functionalist which is a philosophical
way of describing the mind then yeah
totally ello which is object-oriented
ontology which is another trendy bit of
the only bit of philosophy and I said of
course so do you think you have a soul
no thank you much
kind of dare to ask when there has a
question on this particular topic very
nice talk have a question for you we
engineers like to build machines to be
predictable
to be reliable to be objective but I
wonder if you want to produce real
conscious machines we don't need to have
these machines to be subjective and how
can we enjoy this objectivity and
somehow contradict our own goals so this
is a question about subjectivity versus
objectivity which cuts the nub of the
mind-body problem is that my internal
states are subjective I can't have an
objective view of my Intel so it's very
difficult for me to describe what it is
that makes a bat a bat you know it's the
thing that only a bat can know if I knew
how to programme machines to have
subjective States I'd probably be a very
wealthy man I think the what is going to
come down to is behaviour and if it
behaves as if it has an opinion
behaviour if it has a subjective view of
the world then that's gonna be fine I'm
gonna be happy so when Google you type
in your search query it says feeling
kind of hungover today I don't feel like
giving you the right results will be
fine with that and will say oh yeah you
know Google but could it is having an
off day but it doesn't actually have to
have an oft it doesn't actually have to
have the internal state to do that and I
think what's happening to be things like
Google now and very sort of predictive
technologies is they're giving us the
impression that they have internal
states and then the rest is just a gloss
of personality and I think people are
going to want to have machines with
personality they're gonna want Moodie
machines because that's what we used to
use to movie
I was really annoyed by that talk
excellent because all through it I was
thinking well that Vick and stones for
the soft investigations cuz the meaning
of a word is essentially it's a game we
play any policing if we're successful in
the game you know any word using justice
in public we've got no access to our
else's subject my instead so if we use
it successfully I mean the meaning of
word is if we use it and no one notices
that we've done it wrong right
and so that just gets through the whole
slew problem so I really think and I
thought right I don't for about he's
anymore he's destroyed metaphysics it's
great and I don't philosophy at that
point but and the other thing is you you
I think you confused the weakness than
the Tractatus with the Vigna Steiner
sort of suffering investigations which
is a bit naughty really is his whole
thing his whole bag was that he
completely changed so you know just
don't don't do that one again
I'm just saying was that a question yes
that's commentary sorrows sorry oh I was
wondering if through your investigations
you have come up with any ideas about
what separates humans from machines and
maybe have any ideas about how we can
perceive things to be true that aren't
no machine can ever deduce the true but
you can answer either I'm more
interested in the first
the opportunity we have with leave the
opportunity we have with AI systems is
that we can have a look inside some of
the time aside from how that conclusion
was found or that opinion state was
found which you can't deal with use and
whether that gives you any insight into
what it's like to be a human mind
I'm also that it does and this is this
is part that just at this talk is that
we're building intelligence in a very
general sense but it's not human
intelligence it's nothing evolved
because it's an embodied primate hi
there yeah I was actually just wondering
if you've ever had chance to talk to
Richard Stallman because you've scared
me off using social media more than he
ever has
cuz I've asked quite it's just the
examples that you've given of how you
can use Twitter to sort of trace what
you've done and then follow you up on it
really does sort of show that when he
talks about these things monitoring and
tracking you yeah he's got a point
everyone thinks he's a BB paranoid freak
but he's caught him on it I think if
he's if you start thinking about the
ramification of particularly the social
media stuff where my interaction on
social media is very much an ephemeral
thing something right now I want to say
it some people see it they might respond
great let's move on but we're doing that
our an infrastructure that's data mining
that stuff I storing it forever forever
and human minds are not like that we
forget stuff and we expect people to
forget but by having this stuff you know
there forever is fundamentally different
from the way that we behave but it's
doing it in a way that we think is
doable yeah I think we're really useful
to show to school kids saying that
employers really can use stuff that they
pay and now in the future if your bot
can do it oh yeah yeah there's a lot
more to be doing that you know try to
rank back the creepiness
Elinor and remain high am
you've been very eloquent and careful
about separating humans from BOTS and
and how we're different and how we as
humans might project onto them and so on
but I'm wondering why you gave all of
your bots gender Derick was a man and
BFF bot with the world and you're not
the first to call me on that one
part of the humanizing of a Twitter bot
is to make it as human as possible
humans tend to have agenda that they
express right we won't go into that kind
of worms about you know what I would
agree on getting at the the fact that
alex is a woman was very much driven by
that image I don't if you recognized the
meme image that she comes from which is
the creepy girlfriend image which is an
over over attentive girlfriend I think
it's called who's this woman who made it
was a kind of comedic trope about oh I
really really love you
a bit too much and got a bit creepy so
she came out of that because of the
amount the image that I wanted to use it
has crossed my mind to run exactly the
same thought as a black male avatar see
what happens just to see what happens
because the bot doesn't care about
gender but you're when you see that
little square pop up next to us saying
you make all sorts of assumptions and
I'm very aware of that and I think yeah
it's solid I won't apologize for
choosing a woman but I'm aware of the
complex issues surrounding it